un bureau de tabac sur une place de
village rien de plus anodin et pourtant
ce qui s'est passé dimanche à 2h37 ne
l'est pas anodin le téléphone a sonné
chez nous donc l'alarmé s'est déclenchée
donc réveillés en sursaut on a regardé
le téléphone et puis on a accès à la
vidéo en fait et c'est là qu'en
regardant la vidéo j'ai vu qu'il y avait
le plein de brouillard dans la dans le
magasin donc c'est bon bah y'a quelqu'un
qui est rentré dans le magasin savait
pas encore qu'il y avait une voiture
dans le magasin et voici les images
volées quelques heures plus tôt à loin
cette renault mégane lancé en marche
arrière défonce la vitrine et envoie
tout valdinguer avant de s'immobiliser
le chauffeur descend mais déjà le
magasin est envahie par un épais
brouillard
on y voit pas à 10 cm les voleurs
renonce et s'enfuit dans un second
véhicule dans le magasin les dégâts sont
considérables
les bureaux de tabac sont devenus une
cible privilégiée des braqueurs
malheureusement depuis quelques années a
eu prix du tabac fait que ça devient
quelque chose de convoiter gérant de ce
bureau de tabac à montceau les mines
un responsable de la profession pour la
saône-et-loire confirme on a dû revoir
huit braquages cette année donc beaucoup
la nuit - en journée donc c'est bien
parce que les buralistes sont pas dans
les bureaux de tabac donc c'est moins
sensible mais bon on se protège le mieux
qu'on peut tous les quatre ans on a un
contrat avec l'état qui nous permet de
faire quinze mille euros de travaux de
sécurité qui va de la vidéo de la larme
et maintenant également les brouillards
la protection par brouillard est indiqué
sur la vitrine par cet autocollant si
les braqueurs l'ont repéré au préalable
ils renonceront probablement mais
l'écriteau est très petit peut-être trop
discret une autre protection efficace ce
sont des plots devant la vitrine
le buraliste de branges l'avait demandé
à la mairie qui lui a refusé
il n'est pas trop tard pour changer
d'avis